these are new pictures from Kazakhstan
where Soyuz spacecraft just touched down
American astronaut Nick Hague and two
other crew members from the
International Space Station returned to
Earth safely Hague spent more than 200
days in space he survived a dramatic
launch abort last October we remember
this before getting a second chance to
fly into space and just before he left
the space station Hague told mark
Strassmann what he's learned over the
last year mark good morning to you good
morning Nick Hague Space dream was a
struggle but worth it over the last six
months he is orbited the earth more than
3200 times we talked to him on his last
day aboard the space station just hours
before he suited up to come home Nick
Hague now outside the International
Space Station this is Nick Hague walking
about 250 miles above the rest of us his
earth view and his life view both
changed to be able to look down and see
the earth for what it is and realized
that we're on this very special place
this precious island in this abyss of
darkness the change in perspective up
here is profound and you can definitely
feel it for six months Higgs home has
been the International Space Station but
his emotional space ride began before he
got here
last October his ride to space a Russian
Soyuz rocket had to abort mid-flight a
booster malfunction disintegrating
beneath him the Soyuz abort system flung
the capsule carrying Hague and a Russian
cosmonaut to safety back on the ground
this hug from his wife Katie was longer
than usual you realize in that moment
this could have been really bad when we
talked to the couple last December
NASA was giving Hague what he wanted
another shot at space with another Soyuz
launch nervous I'm nervous oh yes yes
it's scary to be the spouse and to watch
it from the outside is very scary but
this Soyuz flight reached the space
station without a hitch context is
confirmed the
keg of NASA the next one through the
hatch it's a mix of emotions they're the
relief of finally accomplishing it
the knowing the the sacrifice that had
been put in up to that point not just by
me but by my family while in space the
44 year old Hague has done three
spacewalks performed a series of science
experiments and lived a microgravity
lifestyle but it's time to head back to
Houston and what are you gonna miss most
about space I miss things just floating
and myself being able to just float
around for four six months if you got
pretty good at at space gymnastics we'll
give it a shot here looks pretty good to
me I got to tell you mark that never
gets old since 1961
only 358 Americans have ever been in
space they all defied long odds to get
there but none quite like Nick Hague
what does your space experience say
about the power of second chances life
is full of adversity and and what
defines you is how you encounter that
adversity and whether you bounce back
from it or not and so I think second
chances are really moments in life where
you can reflect on what's important and
why you're committed to what you're what
you're committed to Hague also can't
wait to see his family again let's face
it six months is a long time apart so I
emailed his wife Katie to ask whether
there was some big Hague family
homecoming in the works she told me that
their big plans are to eat pizza and
drink wine again Katie Hague two
particularly surprised that not really
surprised that he wanted to go back
again but I would imagine the family
would be nervous what was that big red
blob that he ate I was looking at that
like what is that it looks like jello
that's not part of my space experience
yeah he's gonna miss floating fun I feel
like the the no shoes policy apparently
got their socks on you got all the
equipment we can try that
here all right Thank You mark I
appreciate it